Even though composition of functions
probably felt quite new at the beginning
of this lesson, you've actually been
doing it since the very first lesson of
this course.
There, we came up with an equation for
the amount of money that Grant has left
at any given time.
Initially, we said that the money Grant
has left Is equal to the money he got
from his venture capital funders, minus
the total amount of money he spent so far.
Here, we're using dollar amounts for all
these different quantities.
Then, however, we found out that money
spent changed as time passed.
Then we got a second equation, showing
that the total amount of money spent is
equal to the money Grant spends per month
times the number of months that have
passed, or the number of months he's been
in business.
Let's get some variables and numbers back
in here, to make everything look a bit cleaner.
Let's say that the money Grant has left
is called M.
And as we knew before, he started out
with $3 million from his venture capitalists.
Let's also give total money spent a new
name, like S.
Well that looks way nicer.
We can see M is actually a function of S.
It depends on S.
So I'm going to change this left side of
the equation to read M of S.
But, S itself is a function of the number
of months that have passed.
Since Grant spends a set amount iof money
per month, that monthly spending number
was $100,000.
So if we say that number of months is
just equal to n, then we have another function.
S equals 100,000 n.
And actually, since S is a function of n,
we should rewrite this side over here.
This should say S of n.
Making it abundantly clear that as n
changes, S is going to change as well.
Taking all this into account, what do we
get for M of S of n?